[Music]
in look up news huh
I feel like that was a gullible thing Oh
submitted by I love you do oh [ __ ] love
you too
a university created a center for
digital wellness for students to have a
digital detox Oh try that all the time
what's a digital detox did you throw
your phone away it was like they use
digital electronics your body's not like
get rid of the addiction tears toefl my
phone is like the Lord of the Rings ring
really England I thought you need it and
I'm like know what it's doing heavy
she's a virgin so much or Thor the
[ __ ] volcano but you should make a
rule on to look at your phone in bed
that's what I did and you significantly
cut you night shifts on time nature you
know what the night shift is number it
takes out the blue light oh so you still
use your phone I love it
no but then it calms your eyes down it's
the blue light that come to me imma stop
using the phone in bed Joey you're they
make it easier than a job talking to an
addict does that me I so I told David
about the night shift he said thank you
now I could sleep and then I can't
because I'm inspired by using the night
shift now John's phone longer too but if
you have an iPhone you flip it up
right here my night shift on ya takes
out the blue Oh John I don't know why
you want to die socratic a meter it's
gonna help him sleep
trust me you can I don't believe these
cat cold turkey I can't call Turkey me I
need here's what stops me from sleeping
because if you wakes up before me he
gets on his phone and then when he's
awake he makes noises like laughing it
really sweet in here look at this and
get out of bed so it's just like like oh
my god you just clear this throw it in
like cops and stuff and I'm like it's
fine but these using their phone to bed
I'm just saying maybe don't use the
phone in bed while you're trying to
sleep or when you're waking anytime yeah
she's gone wrong now he could use it in
the living room because of what [ __ ]
nearest phone dude yeah use it for the
phone Dee I know I feel like okay
Liberty University [ __ ] gold
Liberty University that's in Virginia is
a non-profit Christian University they
are the ones that have created this
detox Wellness Center and so um yeah so
it's all led by dr. Sylvia Hart's friend
and she's the founder and partner bridge
really how would you pronounce that I
mean I like the way you pronounce it
what is it heart bridge Fred Fred Raven
it J is seven red per fridge fridge no J
silent Yad hmm okay well that's remain
and didn't call her Silvio then I like
dr. Sylvia so she's she's the founder
and executive director of the center and
she also holds a master's degree in
counseling and a doctorate in leadership
and actually certified in Internet
addiction and recovery coaching so she's
she goes around the school telling kids
to look up which in the name of like her
campaign to like detox from digital
things so this is like one example I
like her posters that should have around
the school it says look up engage in
conversation oh my god they are living
in a [ __ ] dystopian future that this
is a real page-turner yeah and it's like
done like an old fifties poster right
like look up engage in conversations
that's something that we need okay but
real here's the thing that I like one
member where they outlawed texting and
driving like before you could text and
drive in your car like this is like 2008
after they made that law whenever I see
a copper guy oh [ __ ] and I'll just text
impress and then it would make me want
to text and drive like like I'd be like
well that reminds me I got a text and
mom
oh why she and then I would reach for my
phone while I saw the cop remind me to
text someone oh yeah really those
posters every time I look at them I'm
like oh but I see a girl looking at her
phone like oh that's where I got to
check that email I'm gonna hang in my
head right now as I'm looking at that
poster I'm like oh [ __ ] I gotta go check
my phone so it just doesn't work for you
you know it was like individual question
so this doctor suggests not using cell
phones for non-emergencies in the
evening or to designate technology for
you villains in your home these are some
suggestions she she also led the first
digital detox retreats where students
spent a weekend at a camp with no Wi-Fi
access and they were encouraged to spend
time in prayer in Bible study and in
face-to-face conversation with others
torture God please give me Wi-Fi that I
really need it now I know I need it more
than ever you know me so I'm on a plane
and there's no service I'm like yeah so
similar went to Bali and it was 21 hours
and like I thought we'd be able to use
like the internet in the air and like it
was just really shitty Wi-Fi and like
you couldn't use it at all oh I thought
so trapped
Oh like I'm in this plane for 21 hours I
can't even look at my email like the
world's happening around me and I don't
even know yeah I had a reader bro yeah
you know reading books over now so I put
my phone behind the page so there's
still a blue light coming from
I was like keyless ballast can be okay
yeah but those doctors are saying so she
cost a lot of recent studies and she
says that recent studies have shown that
30 percent increase in narcissism and 40
percent decrease in empathy are in
people today we're using so much
technology and also in a survey of 620
teenagers 78% of them checked their
devices hourly and 72% of them needed to
immediately respond to whatever
notifications that they had and pretty
much an average person checks their
phone about 150 times a day holy [ __ ]
now maybe in the first hour yeah [ __ ]
amateurs I don't like overdose on
technology so much to the point where
when I did nature I'm like yeah yeah why
I need sunsets and beautiful views and
you become [ __ ] idiot yeah no
disrespect to me Oh
Grand Canyon here I come let me take a
picture yeah oh I didn't get a good
[ __ ] panorama [ __ ] do it again follow
this chain ah [ __ ] you I wish that I
wish I could stare at this guy and just
look at my phone instead of the sky and
it's all just my phone
all around you know that's all that is
is wiping and you know that you know
where an app where you can point your
phone anywhere and it shows you what
start Israeli inoculation yeah so like
heal again this guy in Sevilla you're
away no instagrams over there Facebook
okay I was like we headed okay
head over that us what snapped my
snapchat versus I would be sticked out
up I'm a big [ __ ] it I'm sure VR will
make it possible for you oh yeah it's so
stick I like that idea
this is like the complete opposite I
wasn't talking to Jack I'm going to push
it on us yeah I feel they are also
saying that overuse of Technology leads
to depression any deities threat or
ability to read nonverbal condition
shows me all my shortcomings that's all
and I'm like yes I gotta get better it's
hard not to look at things I like
everyday I mean it's not back in a day
you'd have to go to like a car
dealership to look at cars or magazines
you have to wait once a month for these
pictures to come but every day I can
look at the car like a look at guns that
could look at all kinds of stuff people
dancing whatever learning curve these
days is super like I could learn [ __ ]
really fast
I like house before the phone you would
go somewhere to watch people dancing and
you're sitting there like that watching
people like doing anything is like this
was worth the trip you had to go places
you had a learning curve though because
I mean that's why I think like for some
people college is a scam like unless
you're a profession that like really
means the degree like a lawyer a doctor
like were you absolutely neither degree
like information is at your fingertips
like anything you need to learn you can
watch a video tutorial on it and you can
learn it immediately yeah but with
college you can go into a lot of debt
yeah exactly it is a real life
experience because if you don't have
that you don't know what's what living
is like right you want you to liberate
it from dead you're like oh I feel like
where I just started before I started
this whole money thing yeah yeah so
Liberty University's age when they they
posted a blog post about this digital
detox center and at the end of it they
posted these 10 steps to digital
wellness with me sound a lot like 10 the
sentiment it's is so cheesy you know
would you like I'm sure it's great I'm a
pledge to always wait
step number one it's not I tweet
therefore I am think twice before you
post tweet text or upload it
watch your digital footprint because
they're permanent three unplugs take a
digital tasks once a week or once a
month invest in relationships real
people come virtual ones establish
digital boundaries limit when you use
digital devices and how much time you
spent on them find things you enjoy
doing in real life and do them is
weirdly get outside take walk feel the
Sun and breathe fresh air power down and
get some sleep your brain can't drive
without there's a lot of like the first
sentence is aggression yeah why is it
like a lot of tests yeah and then not
can cultivate your God space daily take
time to be still and know that He is God
wait what the [ __ ] why is that part of
it it's written school dude [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I'm doing the Church of the
cellphone homie
there is only one God we're created but
wait repent 1 the temple and it won't be
a good steward use technology for God's
glory I think what is this you know what
confuses me is like when did people
forget to be young like what did they
grow up like this [ __ ] lame I'm
pretty sure no one did Yeah right no one
no one go hey man we got to be hip to
the cool if I can do this it's like no
everybody understood and what kid
desires were and all that stuff and then
somewhere along line you forget you
disconnect right but I have a solution
on how if you want people to do
something you just got to give them a
better option exactly hey guys why do
you want to jack off on an Internet when
you can really have someone in the u.s.
you can jack off in front of a girl and
put in the pay in the flesh that's a lot
better when you have an audience so cool
just in the corner and your students
okay go and you're staring at oh right
like look at look disturbing and deeply
into the eye you know saying it's way
better it's way better better why would
you want to do it
at home hey guys you know how great it
is to go to the beach instead of looking
at pictures of the beach yeah oh good my
if you have a shuttle that picks you up
and takes you places that's the internet
detox but you can't have your phone on
the shuttle mm-hmm so I need to go to
some really car gonna remember those
memories if you can't here's a cool way
hello amount of people do you want to
contact me and everybody else you see go
ahead and check the description box
below and follow our social medias is
the Grahams and Twitter's for more
videos click up there baby
[Music]